Der large hadron collider kurz lhc hat mal wieder für eine sensation gesorgt zum ersten mal wurde am cern in genf
der zerfall des berühmten higgs boson zwei bottom quarks nachgewiesen wie bitte
warum das eine absolute sensation ist und wie es jetzt weitergeht klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja so sehen sie aus die data tipps des vereins genauer des large hadron collider kurz lhc hier sind
600.000 protonen kollisionen mit annähernder lichtgeschwindigkeit
drauf eine halbe stunde laufzeit am lhc hier am atlas detektor werden diese daten unter anderem
aufgezeichnet und im juni 2012 wurde in diesen daten zum ersten mal das higgs boson entdeckt ein
absolutes teilchen durch dieses teilchen konnte die existenz des feldes nachgewiesen werden es verschafft alle masse die
eigenschaft von materie die die raumzeit krümmt und so uns zb hier auf die erde zieht das wisst ihr ja aus meinem video über die
relativitätstheorie
gravitation ist keine kraft sondern die krümmung der raumzeit und die eigenschaft der materie masse die die krümmung
verursacht verleiht das higgs fällt der materie das ganze geschah am lhc eine der größten und teuersten
maschinen der menschheit 3 milliarden hat sie gekostet ein ring mit einer länge von knapp 27
kilometern ausgestattet mit mächtigen detektoren in den protonen oder blei und mit fast lichtgeschwindigkeit kollidieren
bei diesen kollisionen zerfallen die teilchen in ihre bestandteile und diese werden mit den riesigen detektoren im idealfall dann
aufgespürt im laufe der jahrzehnte wurde ein standardmodell der
elementarteilchenphysik aufgestellt und am lhc
und seinen vorgängern wurde dieses modell mit seinen quarks lab tonen und posen immer wieder bestätigt beim zerfall des
explosions in zwei bottom quax war der nachweis des zerfalls und damit des standardmodells
allerdings etwas tricky weil diese teilchen auch bei anderen zerfalls vorgängen entstehen und das obwohl
explosionen am meisten in diese beiden teilchen zerfallen
nach dem standardmodell zerfallen higgs boson in 60 prozent der fälle in diese beiden quarks aber
lhc koalition erzeugen große mengen von buttons fahren das macht es schwer
diejenigen herauszufiltern die vom zerfall des higgs bosons stammen so kerstin tack man vom atlas detektor am cern
wie also den zerfall des higgs bosons finden künstliche intelligenz also
lernfähige algorithmen waren die lösungen sie suchten in den daten nach zerf allen bei denen auch jeweils ein zb sohn oder ein velo sohn
auftritt und das ist jetzt gelungen
dieser nachweis ist ein meilenstein
in der erforschung des higgs bosons wir haben damit nun alle kopplungen des higgs boson mit den schweren quarks und elektronen der dritten generation
beobachtet und auch alle wichtigen erzeugungsarten dieses teilchens so karl jakob sprecher am atlas damit wurde wieder das standardmodell der
elementarteilchenphysik bestätigt und auch die juka war kopplung also genau die kopplung des higgs feldes mit den geladenen
elementarteilchen wie quarks und laptop durch die sie ihre masse erhalten
wir sind dem vielleicht größten
rätsel dass es überhaupt gibt wieder etwas näher gerückt mit unserem
experimenten kommen wir dem wesen des higgs teilchens immer näher dem
teilchen das auch als portal zu einer neuen physik gilt das sagt elsen cern direktor für forschung und
computertechnologie so langsam dringen die forschungsteams am cern in einen bereich vor in dem sich eine neue physik verbergen könnte wow
und jetzt in eigener sache wir machen klicks und werbefrei keine briefe mehr
beziehungsweise ihr habt es in der hand
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben schon bald könnte sobald sein schalten wir die werbung von jeweils einem video im monat ab
bis es vor keinem video mehr werbung gibt werdet also mitglied hier unter dem video und bekommt noch
exklusive extra videos live streams wie zum beispiel nächste woche dienstag und noch ein paar weitere privilegien
einfach ihr unter dem video auf mitglied werden klicken
tausend dank an alle die schon dabei sind wenn er immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann hättet mich übrigens bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die bei einigen etwas
unzuverlässige abo box hier auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video mehr einfach hier draufklicken und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch darauf klicken
der large hadron collider am cern wird zum super beschleuniger bis dann
bleibt